President Trump says next month summit
with North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
may be delayed but there is also growing
speculation today that it might not
happen at all there have been reports
that White House aides will go to
Singapore the scheduled side of the
meeting for a crucial planning session
this weekend with North Korean officials
South Korea's president met with
President Trump yesterday to try to get
the summit back on track we shashank is
at the White House with that part of the
story we should good morning good
morning Gail and a change of tone
president Trump is showing some
flexibility toward North Korea opening
the door to the face dismantling of the
country's nuclear program and backing
off from his initial demands that kim
jeong-hoon completely abandoned his
weapons immediately it is seen as a
possible effort to salvage his plan
summit with kim there's a very
substantial chance that it won't work
out and that's okay
president Trump dialed down expectations
that his summit with Kim jong-un will
happen as scheduled on June 12th in
Singapore there are certain conditions
that we want and I think we'll get those
conditions and if we don't we don't have
the meeting one of those conditions
complete denuclearization frustrated the
North Koreans the original broker of the
summit South Korean president moon
jae-in spent the afternoon with
President Trump trying to keep the
meeting alive it's really another part
of the roller-coaster ride
former CIA official Bruce cleaner said
President Trump may have moved too
quickly and asked for too much there are
a lot of land may alliant the land mines
in the details with with North Korea
they have different views of what
denuclearization is Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo would not commit to the
likelihood of a summit I'm not a betting
man so I wouldn't care to predict
whether it will happen mr. Trump
suggested Chinese President Xi Jinping
may have convinced him that the
Singapore summit was not in his best
interest I think there was a little
change in attitude from kim jeong-hoon
so I don't like that still he's not
giving up making a direct plea to Kim
promising a regime change is not part of
the plan we will guarantee your safety
and we've talked about that from the
beginning
he will be safe he will be happy his
country will be rich Klinger says that
president Trump's theory that Chinese
President Xi Jingping had a role in
North Korea's latest position indicates
a misunderstanding of their relationship
and he adds those statements threatening
to pull out of the summit would have
come anyway
John we thanks a safety guarantee as
extraordinary